marché comme une personne âgée à
seulement 13 ans l'exercice est
difficile mais relevé par idrissa dans
le cadre de la semaine bleue à la
verrière au programme un parcours et des
obstacles pour se mettre dans la peau
d'un ancien et comprendre ses
difficultés au quotidien
là c'est pour voir les handicapés comme
manquer s'ils voient les i can't stop et
qu'est ce qu'il ressent c'était
difficile parce qu'en fait il y avait
plusieurs stats et après chaque course
kavala on devait aussi remonté son pied
et son pays il avait des points comme
idrissa les jeunes de la ville
participent toute la semaine à
différentes animations toujours en
binôme avec un senior groupes de paroles
simulateur de vieillesse ou encore
goûter philo l'objectif est de favoriser
le lien entre les générations
tout le monde a un peu peur les uns des
autres les jeunes ont un peu peur des
vieux les vieux ont peur des jeunes et
au bout du compte on n'avance pas
beaucoup
alors que finalement je pense qu'en
effet un jeune qui va chercher la
baguette de pain s'il connaît que sa
voisine à l'état gèle a du mal à marcher
peut-être qui pourra penser tout seul
peut-être que madame untel elle a besoin
de pain je verrai lui proposait je vais
chercher mon pain je vais le chercher le
sien on y arrivera peut-être un jour la
semaine bleue à la verrière se clôture
vendredi soir avec la projection du film
le nouveau stagiaire une histoire dans
laquelle robert de niro retraités
décident de retourner dans le monde du
travail entouré de jeunes collègues